you
hi I'm David bomber and I'm a member of
this Microsoft strategic prototyping
team we're in part of the AI and
research division today we brought some
receptionist assistant robots we plan to
deploy these later on in building 99 to
help receptionists be able to stay at
their posts yet still do more within the
building and then also be able to
interact with a wider range of people
this particular robot is going to help
us retrieve items from inside the
building and then deliver them to people
it's using a combination of local
processing and cloud processing to do
image recognition and motion planning
and the result here is that very
different from an industrial setting
where everything is repeated this robot
is able to figure out the situation at
the time and is actually able to
retrieve the beverage from the inside of
them the inside of the refrigerator
so over here there's a bit of a view of
what's going on and part of the process
for figuring out how to move is to run
simulations and when a simulation is
found that actually works as a solution
here then that data is provided to the
robot that commands the joints into the
specific sequences needed to actually
grab the beverage
so one thing we can see here as we're
waiting some of the computing costs of
these various tasks can affect the the
quality of this scenario in different
ways
so what we're very interested to know is
what makes sense to run here locally and
what makes sense to actually ship up to
cloud up to the cloud
so if those kinds of optimizations of
where the code is actually running
potentially can speed up this scenario
but as you can see it's able to
effectively get the task completed so we
think this is one step along a story
that's going to continue about a
beautiful relationship between humans
and robots
you